Joy is dumber than a stump and Pete
blames Trump mayor Pete also known as
the transportation secretary finally
visiting East Palestine Ohio to check
out the aftermath of the toxic train
derailment which begs the question who's
home breastfeeding the baby
[Laughter]
[Applause]
fantastic
he took all responsibility for the wreck
apologize to each and every townsperson
and vowed to never ever let this happen
again just kidding he blamed Donald
Trump
it's been Secretary of Transportation
for two years now how long can you blame
the Trump Administration for all your
failures
let me say this
I will take responsibility for how I do
my job it is time for the Trump
Administration uh alumni to take
responsibility for their deregulation
and join us in calling for us to us all
this country to reverse course okay well
why don't you just reverse course right
[Laughter]
by the way good question mystery
reporter
I mean the guy is transportation
secretary after freaking all well from
one train wreck to the next Joy Behar
the comedian that inspired me to be a
cab driver
she proved yet again how dumb she really
is on The View when she pointed out that
people in East Palestine voted for Trump
roll this
I don't know why they would never vote
for him
who by the way he plays someone with
deep ties to the chemical industry in
charge of the epa's chemical safety
office that's who you voted for in that
District Donald Trump who reduces all
safety oh you can hear the audience gasp
God the View's so bad I'd rather watch
Jerry Nadler do naked jumping jacks
foreign
but the joke's on me because you know he
doesn't do exercise
uh Guy Benson this story really bothers
me why because over on The View they've
othered conservatives meaning there is
no actual value or premium put on their
lives it's more I think expedient for
them emotionally to be like screw these
people they voted for Trump than to
actually acknowledge like this is a
problem no matter who you voted for if
there's chemicals in the water there's
not like a democratic card that gets you
out of the elbow cancer in five years
yeah I mean it takes a lot to scandalize
the audience at the view by attacking a
conservative too hard I feel like me
making a Kamala Harris joke Here In This
Crowd being like Oh my God
uh but she managed it Joy very in
character for her I will say the one
little sliver of levity out of this
horrible situation is the fact
politically first of all that the bite
Administration allowed Donald Trump to
actually get there first it's just
amazing malpractice on their part and
then Trump shows up in the trumpiest way
handing out his own branded water or
whatever and then he buys McDonald's for
all the First Responders which is a good
look and then the exchange at the
counter where he tells the McDonald's
employee that he knows the menu better
than the employee yeah which is
hilarious and also perhaps the truest
thing he's ever seen I absolutely
believe that's right
cat you and I don't know anything about
trains although we both passed out on
the subway a lot which isn't nothing
but isn't the tell on a basic Common
Sense level isn't the problem with
identity politics obviously we're
appointing unqualified people but
sometimes we're not only appointing
unqualified people but we're overlooking
obvious tells like his name was pothole
Pete that's what he was called who
thought it was an idea to put pothole
Pete in charge of the roads you know
what I'm saying that's like making
Secretary of Education summer school
sell like
what whatever but the question is do you
think maybe there's just hope though
that is an app does like Kamala kjp and
Pete have been that even folks on the
left are going to move past identity
politics because of how harmful it is
I'd like to get a lot further and say
that he's doing a great job in the sense
that he's really proving why we don't
need a transportation secretary because
I mean we didn't have one until not you
know 1966 and it's like oh well what
what would happen if something really
bad happened it's like well something
really really awful did happen and he's
done nothing so let's just not pay
someone to do this when they're not
doing anything and I don't fall for this
narrative that it's oh it's deregulation
that caused this because there's still a
lot of government involvement in these
things and the more government
involvement there is and that that
that's accounted for oh government's got
the more that allows for extreme
corruption and things like corruption
are what cause these sorts of things to
happen
um
just quickly about what Joy Behar said
all of us here you know especially you
know us and guy and you and you are
engaged as well in the media you talk
about the media you guys are fans of the
show you're really plugged into the
media
your average civilian doesn't really
necessarily know what Joy Behar said on
The View today I was talking to my
brother Elliott timff yesterday the
great Elliot the great Elliot Tim but he
was like no she didn't like did she
really say that you know it's their
fault yes what happens it's a great
point because they voted for Trump I
mean he was like pulling out his phone
to Google this like this is unbelievable
because it's horrifying and he's like
and she's back she's on air like she's
getting like how long she's been for I'm
like she's not and it's just so hard to
grasp and it's just things have gone so
insane that you could think that that's
even remotely okay to say yeah it was it
was honestly it was disgusting
um I mean what does it say about the job
Pete booty judges doing Walter that Joe
Biden felt safer taking a train into a
Ukrainian war zone this week
well you know he's doing no job at all
so here's the thing about Pete Buda
judge if I didn't know he was gay if
they didn't keep telling me we was gay I
would think he was a Mormon missionary
that's what I say about God
and there are times with Pete
butterjudge when he seems like a 16 year
old Explorer Scout from Toledo
you'd think he'd know a lot about trains
he's got all of the short haircut and
boring kind of simple looks of the
straight young teenager and none of the
knowledge of trains
that's really funny
John what does Joy Behar hate more
Republicans of the treadmill oh I think
probably Republicans but when her
picture was up there I can't help
picture in her with round glasses she
looks just like John Lennon yeah
oh man wow I want to give peace a chance
all right we'll find no it's uh it's
tough to watch but if anybody wants
tickets to The View I can get him
they're 25 to get in 100 to get out
hahaha
just telling jokes just
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else